this morning I caught a really expensive
taxi and I went to Google's offices in
Pima and there I gave a 10-minute
presentation to teachers and other
technology coordinators about how school
is using Google Apps which is like
Google Drive and Google Sites and all
that kind of thing
so in the spirit of things I thought
while I was there I would record a short
video about some of my thoughts on
technology so enjoy I work a lot with
technology I'm a bit of a nerd so I
guess that's been sort of part of my
life for a long time but I had a lot of
thoughts about it and particularly about
the way the younger generation is using
technology which I've had sort of
circulating around my head for ages and
I've shared with people in conversation
every now and then but I want to tell a
lot of people this so three things I
want to say about technology
particularly how relates to schools
because that's kind of the context that
I mainly think about it so firstly
technology's really good it's really
good for learning and for schools and
probably if you're watching this video
you're the kind of person who thinks
that's a no-brainer
but I think it's still we're saying
because I continually encounter people
maybe because of the kind of job that I
have who are resistant they're really
skeptical about technology and that's
often for good reasons like they've been
doing things without technology for a
long time and it's worked really well
but technology's really great
I mean sometimes the people who tell me
this who are skeptical about it they say
you know we should be back with
chalkboards and pen and paper and that's
the way to learn the traditional way the
irony of saying that is that chalkboards
and pen and paper are themselves you
know quite modern technologies when it
comes to education so I want to put in a
verb for technology and how it's used in
learning it's got a really significant
value the second thing I want to say
though is that that's not entirely true
of the skeptics and the naysayers they
do have a point and that is a even when
you benefit from technology lots of
really cool ways like how much
information you've got access to or how
you can work together with people even
when you're not in the same place when
you gain things you also lose things so
for instance it's tons of research that
talks about how
when you type up something with your
fingers you can on a keyboard you can
put in all the data and that's great you
can access it forever set you know good
for your memory you would think but
research shows that actually riding with
your hands there's something about that
tactile sensation that actually helps
you to think and remember and purchase
and engage with the kinds of things that
your the ideas that you're writing so
just think about that that reading you
know off a screen versus reading in a
book they're not equivalent things right
and as a generation we're sort of going
more and more towards just giving
ourselves wholly over to technology and
I think I want to throw up a sort of red
flag and be cautious about that so I
guess the third thing I want to say is
would you consider being really
discerning and careful with how you use
technology consider this have you ever
thought about spending a week or a month
with just zero technology away from your
smartphone do you activate your Facebook
or Twitter or whatever think about that
give that a go if you think that's
ridiculous I can survive without my
smartphone for a week you're probably
exactly the kind of person it needs to
have a break from it and you know maybe
you might discover after a week or a
month your ability to remain focused
rather than distracted by your 50
million tabs or your instant
notifications on your smart phone or
your ability to think about something
for a long period of time and be
undistracted about it that might come
back to you and you might appreciate it
and not realize that you'd lost it
before